we're getting closer and closer to the
xbox series x launch
but if you're an xbox live gold member
who doesn't want to spend money when
that comes out
good news the free games with gold
lineup for september has been announced
here's what's coming soon first up on
xbox one is the division
ubisoft's looter shooter set in a new
york city overtaken by disaster
as a member of the division you've got
to take down rogue agents and collect
better weapons and gear
and you can do that with friends online
you can deploy anytime
in september as the game will be
available all month long
moving from point and shoot to point and
click september's second xbox one game
is the book of unwritten tales 2.
the sequel once again pokes fun at
famous fairy tales
and of course it gives you plenty of new
puzzles to solve in the land of
avantasia
the book of unwritten tales 2 will be
available from september 16th through
october 15th
now don't tune out just yet these xbox
360 games are backwards compatible for
you xbox one players too
the first of these is the blob 2 a
platformer where you play as
well a blob as you platform and paint
your way through the levels
you'll have to deal with the evil inkies
and big bosses
deblob 2 also has multiplayer to check
out with your friends
it'll be available to download from
september 1st through the 15th
finally there's armed and dangerous an
original xbox game that's being brought
forward
like the book of unwritten tales this
game also pokes fun at pop culture
although it's a full-on shooter in this
case there's a wide variety of weapons
to wield and you can grab the game and
see them for yourself from september
16th through the 30th
and those are your free games with gold
for september 2020
remember that you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on gamespot
and stay tuned as we report on the new
games with gold lineup every month
[Music]
you